bon sens nous sommes le lundi 8 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
accompagné de nous inviter mais
également des journalistes de la
rédaction
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres de cette édition un premier pas
vers la fusion vendredi dernier les
assemblées départementale des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines ont
conclu la création d'un établissement
public de coopération
interdépartementale commun elles
viennent également d'acter la fusion des
sociétés d'économie mixte d'aménagement
et deux départements et les visites
ministérielles se multiplier dans le
département lors de sa venue ce matin
sur le campus scientifique et technique
de l'entreprise alain colas à magny les
hameaux le secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports
alain vidalis l'annoncé un plan
d'investissement 2016 pour l'entretien
du réseau routier national vendredi
dernier c'était ségolène royal ministre
de l'écologie qui était en visite sur le
site d'airbus aux mureaux et apprendre
les gestes qui sauvent en situation
exceptionnelle
une initiative lancée par la préfecture
des yvelines ce week-end une cession
gratuite dispensée par le 10 78 et la
croix-rouge a eu lieu au lycée descartes
de montigny le bretonneux
nous y reviendrons et hommage au préfet
erignac et 18 ans jour pour jour après
l'assassinât du préfet claude erignac
abattu en corse en février 1998 la ville
de versailles lui a rendu hommage ce
samedi
une allée ainsi qu'un monument
historique lui ont été dédiées l'aller
claude erignac qui a été inaugurée en
présence du préfet serge e morvan du
maire de versailles et de gérard larcher
le président du sénat claude erignac
avait en effet était préfet des yvelines
de juin 1993 à janvier 1996 avant d'être
nommé sur l'île de beauté et vendredi
derniers les assemblées départementale
des hauts-de-seine et des yvelines ont
délibérément ont délibéré simultanément
et approuvé la création de
l'établissement public de coopération
interdépartementale ainsi que la fusion
des sociétés d'économie mixte
d'aménagement des deux départements
les deux présidents des conseils
départementaux pierre bédier et patrick
de villejean concrétise ainsi leur
volonté de rapprocher les deux
territoires williams elle pour ce
reportage
c'est un premier pas vers un
rapprochement des départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
le 5 février les conseils départementaux
des deux territoires ont voté pour la
création d'un établissement public de
coopération interdépartementale situé à
vélizy villacoublay
une structure qui selon les deux
présidents devraient permettre des
économies
il n'y a personne d'embauché pour cela
ce sont nos services qui conjointement
travaillent ensemble à la fusion
progressive par exemple pour la voirie
nous allons mettre en somme notre parc
d'engins tout de suite c'est à dire que
évidemment les yvelines comme les au
stand puis se servir des engins qui
appartiennent aux deux départements
un rapprochement vu d'un mauvais oeil
par le syndicat cgt qui craint une
dégradation des conditions de travail et
d'éventuelles suppressions de postes
bien entendu une autre fusion ne va pas
créer d'emplois mais après il va pas y
avoir de disparition brutale a d'emplois
on va tout simplement faire ce qu'on a
déjà commencé à faire mais à une autre
échelle c'est ne pas renouveler les
contrats ne pas renouveler tous les
départs en retraite etc etc
si on veut pouvoir un jour faire baisser
les impôts il faut qu'il y ait moins de
fonctionnaires également abordé le
rapprochement de la sem92 et yveline
aménagement une fusion des sociétés
mixtes de développement prévu pour la
fin de l'année 2016 qui nécessitera
l'accord des collectivités territoriales
actionnaires un plan qui s'inscrit dans
un éventuel projet de fusion des deux
départements est un projet de fusion qui
je le rappelle est déjà contestée au
sein même de la majorité du conseil
départemental des yvelines
les conseillers départementaux yves
vandewalle et christine boutin ont
demandé à leur président d'effectuer un
référendum auprès de la population
yvelinoise une requête également
formulée par le parti socialiste des
yvelines
et ce matin le secrétaire d'état chargé
des transports a visité le campus
scientifique et technique de
l'entreprise colas basée à magny les
hameaux
alain vidalies a aussi annoncé le plan
d'investissement de 2016 pour
l'entretien du réseau routier national
ainsi que les voies navigables
avec près de 300 millions d'euros
investis pour les réseaux routiers le
budget a triplé depuis 2012
la nouveauté était sur place près de 300
millions d'euros pour les réseaux
routiers sur l'année 2016 c'est le
campus scientifique et technique de
colas à magny les hameaux qui a choisi
alain vidalis le secrétaire d'état pour
l'annoncer colas entreprises françaises
est leader mondial de la construction de
routes
très concrètement sert faire refaire des
voix refaire des de la signalétique
refaire des bordures tout ce qui
aujourd'hui s'appelle l'entretien etc
est indispensable l'enjeu c'est de ne
pas se trouver sur le routier confrontés
à la situation qui est une réalité
aujourd'hui sur le ferroviaire
c'est à dire que si vous ne faites pas
un entretien régulier le vieillissement
du réseau vous impose ensuite de faire
d'énormes travaux de restructuration
près de huit déplacements survie ce faux
sur le million de kilomètres de routes
que compte la france
pour le budget 2016 un crédit
exceptionnel de 120 millions d'euros est
ajouté il ya un très gros besoin parce
que depuis six ou sept ans effectivement
on a beaucoup moins 1,30 retenu les
routes on a perdu 30 % d'activité sur
ses six ou huit dernières années avec le
25000 emplois de perdus et donc on
constate tous effectivement un certain
nombre de problèmes de difficultés sur
les routes ce budget financera 400
chantiers à travers toute la france dans
les yvelines une dizaine sont concernés
dont la mise en sécurité des zones
cyclables de la rn 10 ou encore
l'entretien des chaussées de la
nationale 12 et la ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie ségolène royal et elle
vendredi en visite officielle officielle
sur le site d'airbus défense n space aux
mureaux l'occasion de rappeler le succès
des dernières missions de ariane 5 avec
le lancement du satellite intelsat 29
mais surtout l'importance du secteur
pour appréhender les problématiques
environnementales et leur rôle
d'observation en ce qui concerne le
réchauffement climatique
les images sont signés fanny bourdillon
découverte du crieu ce passé du hall
d'intégration de les tâches principales
d'ariane 5
une première visite pour ségolène royal
trop de l'écologie du site airbus
défense et espace aux mureaux qui compte
2500 employés
si ce fleuron de l'industrie spatiale
française est à l'ordre du jour c'est
bien pour des questions
environnementales
toutes les activités spatiales
scientifique et technique et techniques
sont absolument cruciaux crucial parce
que ça permet au fonds d'accélérer et
d'être à la hauteur des engagements qui
ont été pris à la conférence de paris
sur le climat plus bien sûr toutes les
autres activités spatiales qui parfois
des ont des connexions très directe ou
indirecte avec la question de l'avenir
de la planète
ariane space appartient à la
coentreprise airbus safran launcher
c'est le leader mondial des services de
lancement lors de la cop 21 en novembre
dernier l'importance de la coopération
internationale et de l'apport des
satellites pour l'observation du
changement climatique a été mise en
avant
au delà des problématiques
environnementales ariane space se veut
aussi éco responsable nous attachons une
grande importance au respect de
l'écologie en particulier sur le site
des mureaux nous avons investi des
sommes très importantes pour avoir une
chaufferie biomasse qui alimente
l'ensemble des bureaux d'études et des
ateliers du site des mureaux est évident
que les lanceurs
un impact important sur le respect de
l'environnement sur la sécurité sur
l'observation de la terre sur le climat
sur la météorologie
prochain objectif pour ariane céris
démarrer le développement d'ariane 6 le
lanceur européen du futur il devrait
entre autres améliorer le lancement des
satellites européens de protection de
l'environnement de surveillance du
climat et de météorologie première
réunion publique et première tuile pour
la municipalité de la verrière la
commune proposait samedi matin une
concertation aux habitants autour de la
rénovation du quartier du bois de
l'étang
seulement certains sont loin d'y être
favorable ils craignent de voir les
immeubles détruits sans garantie d'être
relogées sur place dans de nouveaux
programmes
il se base sur une lettre qui aurait été
envoyé par le maire au préfet pour lui
demander l'intégration du secteur dans
un dispositif de projets d'intérêt
régional on écoute tout de suite une
habitante et les explications du maire
adjoint en charge de l'urbanisme
on pense qu'il veut faire deux bâtiments
ou trois même là bas pour les ventres
éventuellement bien joué
enfin bref on sait pas trop où
exactement son projet mais on sait que
c'est parce que les résidences c'est pas
pour les résidents wta new heaven ou
loger ailleurs la rénovation intéresse
le quartier complet les entrées du
quartier les voiries les écoles nous
avons deux groupes scolaires sur ce
quartier le gymnase a déjà été rénové
une nuit dans ce qu'on appelle en ruban
c'est à dire le premier projet de
rénovation urbaine la première campagne
mais évidemment ça concerne l'ensemble
du quartier béton nous voulons pas créer
un quartier neuf en désintéressant des
quartiers plus anciens donc
l'amélioration de l'habitat des
appartements de l'existant tout ça fait
aussi partie de son effectif et nous
accueillons ce soir en plateau avec nous
un mathilde obino bonsoir alors merci je
vous après ce bon vous êtes yvelinoise
vous habitez au chesnay et vous êtes
aussi voilà la fondatrice d'un blog qui
s'appelle la saga des audacieux et votre
premier lieu votre premier livre pardon
sur lequel vous êtes co auteur vient
d'être publié il s'appelle les métiers
de la cuisine
alors tout d'abord j'aimerais qu'on
parle de votre bleu donc la saga des
audacieux c'est un site internet sur
lequel vous partagez vous rencontres
avec des personnalités vous dresser
leurs portraits vous pouvez vous nous en
dire un peu plus alors je vais
travailler dans la presse écrite dans
les médias en général et je trie claude
hasty une valeur très importante très
intéressante et j'ai voulu partir à la
rencontre de ces personnalités des
personnalités politiques des dirigeants
d'entreprise en prenant l'angle de
l'audace et et à chaque fois c'est très
intéressant de d'essayer de voir qu'est
ce qui les anime qu'est-ce qui les
portent au quotidien de leur métier
alors comment justement aussi l'idée de
faire un blog pourquoi justement avoir
choisi ce format savourer ce pont
peut-être bien ce que vous êtes assez
jeune vous vous rappelez vous avez 24
ans je trouve que c'est un média qui est
très interactif puisque après je le
relais sur les réseaux sociaux aussi et
ça permet un public large finalement
aussi bien des jeunes des influenceurs
de pouvoir faire émerger des contenus
et du coup c'est très intéressant de se
servir de cet outil lors de ce support
qui permet de mettre en évidence des
figures auxquelles on en aurait pas
nécessairement parler au départ je pense
à des entrepreneurs des jeunes
dirigeants et qui permet de les mettre
en avant vos buts c'est un peu d'ériger
des modèles des modèles laisse pas
d'autres personnes des envies de
motivation oui oui à travers ces figures
de voir ce qui émerge une capacité à
dire non à faire avancer les choses et
c'est vrai que ce sont des personnes de
deux parcours d'âge voilà d'origines
très différentes et il ya un aspect très
sain critique qui fait avancer les ce
côté là alors justement voilà des
parcours qui inspire les gens c'est un
peu le même principe avec ce livre donc
les métiers de la cuisine qui sont
publiés aux éditions l'étudiant c'est
une première donc ce livre pour vous oui
absolument
comment est né un petit peu l'idée
commence à ces passants vous a contacté
pour pourrait être co auteur / salut oui
alors à la suite justement de ce blog la
sag et d'hésitations avec lequel je
parle à en compte de ces personnalités
on m'a proposé ce projet en partant
cette fois la rencontre de grands chefs
de sommelier pour donner des conseils
aux jeunes aux personnes intéressées
curieuse à cet univers de la cuisine et
c'était il y avait cette idée on parle
beaucoup de la cuisine était vision dans
les médias et finalement d'essayer de
marquer ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
l'envers du décor les coulisses à
travers ces témoignages de deux grands
chais alors justement on a parfois des
clichés par rapport au milieu voilà due
au secteur donc de la cuisine il ya des
choses que vous avez découvert des
choses qui vont étonner peut-être que
vous avez fait votre conquête justement
pour ce livre alors je retiendrai deux
choses à la fois la créativité de la
part de ces chefs s'il ce sont des
artistes la manière dont ils parlent de
ce produit qu'il sublime très souvent et
puis la pédagogie il ya une envie de
d'expliquer justement aux jeunes de
faire partager leurs savoirs d'inciter
sur la ténacité la volonté d'arriver ça
c'était très intéressant informateurs
alors ce livre propose donc un peu un
tour d'horizon à des métiers de la
cuisine alors il ya pizzaïolo chef
barman fin il ya un petit peu tout
expliquer le parcours aussi qu' on doit
effectuer justement pour arriver à ça
c'est un peu pour les jeunes qui sont en
quête d'orientation par rapport au bac
justement là en plein dans la période
oui oui à cette idée finalement j'ose
pas feront forcément franchir cette
porte c'est un métier qui m'intéresse il
ya cette idée on voit là on y va
pourquoi pas moi et
ça peut être intéressant les personnes
en reconversion aussi qu'ils ont
intéressé curieux c'est cet univers
voilà donc on est donc vous à vous avez
24 on vous êtes vous êtes fous niveau
d'étude ya pas si longtemps que ça ça
vous a parlé spécifiquement et vous avez
besoin d'un regard justement jeunes pour
parler de ce milieu aussi l'orientation
de ces dunes gros une question
importante
oui c'est un rôle clé justement pour
pouvoir avancer
et c'est vrai que c'était intéressant
d'aller rencontrer ces chefs alors je
pense à xavier koenig qui l'ancien
malgré le dernier gagnant de top chef
qui est jeune et puis d'autres figures
comme thierry marx ils ont chacun
apporté leur expérience et et qui vont
donner des clés pour les questions
d'orientation justement à ce que voilà
on peut s'offrir des anecdotes par
rapport justement à ces clés pour
justement avancé dans le milieu de la
cuisine
alors oui déjà s'entraîner chez soi par
exemple régulièrement alors bien sûr il
ya l'apprentissage et les différentes
études qui sont mises en place
mais voilà faire preuve de régularité et
puis aussi à jouer sur les saisonnalité
est toujours être en veille
ça c'est important ces chefs ont
témoigné sur ces nécessités de dire
voilà en regardant des magazines en se
promenant dans la rue et c'est d'avoir
toujours un regard vif et se servir
finalement laissé sous inspiration très
variés alors je le dit alors nous aurons
pendant la période des voeux d'admission
post bac c'est un sujet de préoccupation
pour les étudiants est souvent la
cuisine on considère que c'est une
filière courte
enfin il ya beaucoup de devoirs de flers
il ya trois quatre ans d'études
peut-être parfois - est-ce que pour vous
c'est même si sinclair qui est dit un
peu plus technique c'est également voilà
un parcours pour les ambitieux a bien
sûr au contraire ce sont des très beaux
parcours qui s'inscrivent dans la durée
puisque on ne tient pas chef du jour au
lendemain
et voilà c'est cette idée de s'inscrire
dans une perspective et ce sont des très
très beau parcours bien sûr il faut
l'ambition du travail de la rigueur
et voilà ça a été ça a été des
expériences qui sont qui sont
fascinantes qui sont fascinantes aussi
alors un premier livre voilà qu publié à
24 ans qui valait quelle va être la
suite un petit peu pour vous est-ce qui
va y avoir des nouveautés justement par
rapport à votre blog ou par rapport
voilà à vos ambitions personnelles
alors justement par rapport aux blocks
je suis en train de réfléchir par
rapport
au site essayer de voir comment mettre
en place pour suivre
justement à travers la figure du
dirigeant la figure du leadership et est
toujours essayé de créer des liens de
tisser les liens entre les dirigeants
puis les parties prenantes les lecteurs
les internautes
donc voilà en phase de réflexion et si
vous aurez jusqu'à 1 ou 2 conseils à
donner à quelqu'un qui souhaiterait lui
aussi ouvrir son blog
et voilà sur un sur un parcours un peu
similaire au vôtre foncé va ne pas
hésiter à bas à oser à frapper aux
portes et et avancer et voilà moi j'ai
écrit mes premiers articles à 13 ans
j'ai envoyé des rédacteurs en chef et et
ne pas avoir peur finalement est
toujours se dire pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas moi merci beaucoup et mathilde obino
alors voilà je le rappelle les métiers
de la cuisine c'est aux éditions de
l'étudiant et si on veut savoir où
découvrir peut-être un peu plus sur
votre blog on peut retrouver vos écrits
sur le blog la saga des audacieux merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci tout autre sujet à
présent dans le cadre du plan gestes qui
sauvent lancée par la préfecture les
services de secours s'organisent
durant tout le mois de février pour
former sur des actions à adopter en
situation d'exception ces sessions
gratuites dispensées par le 10 78 et la
croix rouge sont également donnés au
sein de certains établissements
scolaires sur volonté du chef de
l'établissement
nous sommes rendus à une de ces séances
au lycée descartes de montigny le
bretonneux william el est patrick jacq
dick smith pour ce reportage
et je sors je sens n'en regarde de
l'autre côté il faut que tu puisse
regarder sa poitrine se soulever masser
défibriller ou poser un garrot ces
gestes auparavant réservé aux
professionnels vont s'étendre au grand
public dans ce lycée de montigny le
bretonneux
la direction s'est impliqué dans une
session de formation aux gestes qui
sauvent et c'est une opération très très
utile
je pense que ça va nous permettre de
sensibiliser les élèves en cas
d'événement grave
parallèlement donc à la mise en place du
ppms du plan de mise en sûreté
dispensés par des bénévoles est mise en
place avec les services de la direction
académique
cette formation ne se substitue pas au
psc1 au programme des gestes à adopter
en situation d'exception comme posé un
garrot
on a vu comment protéger se protéger et
protéger la victime sur une scène
d'accident comment passez une alerte
elle par quels moyens et cetera
on a appris là bas tout ce qu'il a
touché un petit peu à la traumatologie
de l'attentât c'est à dire les
saignements les plus graves les victime
inconsciente qui respire ou qui ne
respire pas donc après les massages
cardiaques et l'utilisation des
défibrillateurs venus volontairement
chacun des élèves reçoit un diplôme à la
fin de la formation
bah je suis contente parce que j'ai
c'est qu'il faudrait sauver des vies et
binche avait pas le faire avant mais
quand j'essaie les gestes je pense que
c'est bien pour l'avenir parce que du
coup tout le monde peut être sauvé et
tout le monde fait un héros une
formation qui répond à une demande suite
aux attentats du 13 novembre de nombreux
français avaient exprimé le souhait de
connaître les gestes utiles pour sauver
des vies en dehors de ces formations en
milieu scolaire la préfecture des
yvelines a organisé 83 cession gratuite
pour le mois de février sur le
territoire et c'est un des projets
phares de joséphine coltman berger la
mère de plaisir le projet ville
solidarité lancée en septembre 2014
commence déjà à prendre forme
le projet concerne six grands axes tels
que de transport le handicap ou la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire les
centres sociaux flora tristan et la
mosaïque prendront le nom de maison des
familles et proposeront différents
ateliers de soutien une troisième maison
des familles a ouvert également ses
portes dans l'ancienne école camille
claudel principal objectif de ces
mesures
améliorer les possibilités
d'accompagnement et de solidarité de la
ville écoutez nous avons
sial très dynamique avec un
accompagnement à la difficulté qui forte
surtout dans le cadre du logement
surtout dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement des femmes isolées par
exemple au niveau de la petite enfance
aussi au niveau du sanitaire le projet
vie solidarité c'est de voir comment de
la petite enfance jusqu'à fin de vie la
ville peut apporter
je dirais un regard un accompagnement et
surtout je dirais un respect c'est ça
qui est important
et comme chaque lundi nous retrouvons
sephora namani pour sa chronique
culturelle bonsoir à sephora saint
fleuret alors cette semaine vous venez
nous dresser un portrait familier à
trois générations maintenant celui de
chantal goya
tout à fait je vais vous ramener à votre
enfant si j'imagine avec chantal goya et
son répertoire merveilleux chantal goya
qui était samedi dernier au théâtre
espace coluche de plaisir pour la
première date de sa nouvelle tournée
avec son spectacle les aventures
fantastiques de marie-rose un ensemble
de 14 nouvelles chansons avec même de
tout nouveaux personnages comme un petit
rat qui s'appelle raccourcis des souris
un loup des koalas qui vont emmener
petits et grands à la découverte d'un
tout nouveau décor également celui du
vieux paris à bord de la mythique
voiture très fleuve jaune
si la main visible
c'est la fête aujourd'hui ses
alors c'est la première date de sa
nouvelle tournée mais c'est un spectacle
qui a l'air un petit peu rodé au théâtre
de paris pendant trois mois du 2 octobre
à janvier dernier spectacle produit à
partir de l'album éponyme sorti en 2015
tout à fait c'est ça l'album les
aventures fantastiques de marie rose qui
est son dix neuvième album faut savoir
que son premier album remonte à 1977
avec voulez vous danser grand mère et
nous expliquer que c'était presque même
par hasard qu'elle a commencé sa
carrière dans la chanson pour enfants
au détour d'une invitation l'émission
télévisée pour aider une amie j'ai un
jour en rencontrer marc et et gilbert
carpentier dans la lave et 75
jean-jacques l'écrivait dès midi comédie
musicale pour eux il manquait cinq
minutes et aimar et icare pensée m'a dit
viennent nous aider parce que
franchement il nous manque cinq minutes
toi qui est disponible est ce que tu
peux venir alors j'ai quitté la campagne
où j'habitais pas loin d'ici
j'ai emmené mes enfants qui avait 5 ans
et 7 ans et jean jacques m'a écrit adieu
les jolis foulards et là ça a été la
folie mais y avait plus de 500000 elles
qui sont arrivés et j'ai compris qu'il
fallait faire quelque chose pour les
enfants
alors depuis 1980 les scènes et tournée
mondiale se sont enchaînés de nombreux
spectacles même en boîte de nuit pour
chantal goya grand rex
olympia zénith casino de paris elle a
collectionné toutes les grandes salles
parisiennes
chantal goya d'ailleurs qui détient le
record de représentation pour une
artiste seul en scène au palais des
congrès avec pas moins de trois cent
cinquante six représentations
chantal voyait c'est aussi plus de 350
chansons et 25 millions de disques
vendus
c'est impressionnant mais en même temps
ça fait 35 ans qu'elle tourne avec la
même équipe c'est son mari d'ailleurs
jean jacques debout qui est le metteur
en scène de tous ses spectacles mais
qu'elle est un peu le secret de sa
longévité sur scène alors vraiment elle
est étonnante une énergie incroyable
déployée sur scène par cet artiste de 73
ans un spectacle moderne qui se se
réinventer à chaque fois beaucoup de
danse et dynamique très vivant et puis
on sent qu'elle aime la scène et son
public c'est interactif
elle fait monter les enfants sur scène
avec leurs parents même parfois qui
viennent déguisés à la façon de ses
personnages son succès tient vraiment à
cette transmission par enfant elle nous
explique à la grande qu'elles sont
compose tout le temps moi je crois que
j'ai connu tous ces enfants qui sont
aujourd'hui des parents je les ai connus
vraiment tout mon public les connu petit
en fin de compte je crois qui allie un
très très affectif entre eux et moi et
ils transmettent aux enfants c'est les
seuls qui transmettent vraiment mes
chansons et mon histoire aux enfants
ainsi que les grands parents vous savez
quand on a un public comme ça de trois
générations
c'est à merveille aux cadeaux alors j'ai
une petite surprise pour vous florane
disait que cet univers a bercé votre
enfance et je vous ai préparé une petite
compilation des grands classiques qui
font partie bien sûr du spectacle je
veux parler de pandi panda le lapin des
cas sinon on regarde
ski
mais elle a fait
allah
bien merci sephora que de bons souvenirs
effectivement j'ai une question aussi
pour vous si vous savez pourquoi chantal
goya s'appelle justement goya parce que
ce n'est pas son vrai nom de famille son
vrai nom c'est chantal de guerre à dieu
coûté non je vous avoue je n'y avais
jamais changé goya peut être par rapport
au peintre espagnol
c'est pas mal vous n'êtes pas loin en
fait c'est son ami le poète et guy
d'arcangues qui lui a dit qu'elle
ressemblait au portrait de manuel osorio
pain justement par le peintre goya un
petit garçon avec de grands yeux noirs
et une collègue une collerette blanche
elle lui a dit que si un jour elle
chantait elle prendrait le nom de goya
vous écouter vous m'apprenez quelque
chose merci oui on en apprend tous les
jours avec la chronique culture merci
beaucoup sephora je le rappelle est
revenue de chantal goya se poursuit en
2016 dans toute la france vous aussi
vous aurez peut-être la chance de
l'avoir
on vous retrouve mercredi pour un
nouveau numéro de kiosques une émission
musicale cette fois-ci l'émission
musicale et bien on a hâte de voir ça et
de la musique au sport il n'y a qu'un
pas on referme cette édition avec un mot
de rugby les semaines se suivent et se
ressemblent pour le sky rugby les hommes
de thomas payen se sont très facilement
imposé face à fontenaisienne sur le
score de 66 à 12 au classement le sky
ruby réalise la bonne opération de cette
13e journée
avec sabine avec sa victoire les
yvelinois compte désormais neuf points
d'avancé sur leur dauphin la montée
l'objectif fixé en début de saison est
donc plus que jamais réalisable est tout
de suite plus de détails avec michael et
demi d'euros pour le 7-8 sport quant à
moi je vous retrouve demain pour un
nouveau numéro du journal je vous
souhaite donc une excellente soirée